TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show,"
coming to you from the Firebase
Summit in Prague.
Now all the sessions are
recorded and available online,
but that's a ton of content
to sift through if you just
want the highlights.
So here you are, the
Firebase Summit top five.
First on the list is
deploying to Firebase Hosting
from Glitch and StackBlitz.
These are two powerful
web-based IDEs.
Now, the demo Rob gave
for this was really cool.
He loaded up a project on Glitch
and added a firebase.json file.
The Deploy to Firebase
button just appeared,
and he clicked it and
selected a project.
And just like that, his Glitch
project was running in Prague.
Now these integrations are
both based on the new Firebase
Management API, which
lets you create and manage
Firebase projects and apps.
Second on our list is
enterprise-grade support
for helping large and complex
enterprises adopt Firebase.
If you already use Firebase's
free support, don't worry,
it's not going away.
This actually adds
support for Firebase
to Google Cloud
Platform support.
So if you already have a
paid GCP support package,
Firebase is now included.
They're ramping
up now with plans
to launch in beta by end of
year and general availability
early next year.
OK, number three.
Firebase Predictions
has graduated out
of beta and into general
availability, which
means it's fully stable and
available for production use.
For those who don't remember,
Firebase Predictions
applies machine learning
to your analytics data
to create dynamic user
groups based on your users'
predicted behavior.
So you can do things like
segment users based on churn
or likelihood to spend.
Also announced today was
that predictions data,
along with Firebase Cloud
Messaging and A/B testing data,
can be exported to BigQuery
so you can run your own custom
analysis of your data and
join it with other data sets.
Also graduating to
general availability
is number four on our list,
Firebase Test Lab for iOS.
Now, Firebase Test Lab is
cloud-based app testing,
and it's pretty awesome.
You can test an
Android or iOS app
across a bunch of devices
and configurations,
and then see logs, videos, and
screenshots in the Firebase
console.
Derek mentioned today that
nearly 100,000 successful tests
have been run over the
last several months, which
along with a few other factors,
like support for iOS 12,
is a great indication of
it being stable and ready
for production use.
Last on our list, and
one of my favorites,
is a new Face Contours API.
It's part of ML Kit,
which means it's
meant to be easy and accessible
for all mobile developers,
whether or not we
have ML experience.
The API is essentially a more
advanced version of the Face
Detection API, giving
you over 100 points
in and around the
face, which means
you can know where things
like the face contour are,
the eyes, eyebrows, the mouth,
where all of them are located,
which can be super
useful for apps
that want to have advanced
filters that center
around the person or
people in the photo.
All right, that's it, our top
five at the Firebase Summit.
Of course, there were a
lot of other announcements
and updates, so links to the
full keynote and session videos
are in the description below.
If you found this video
useful, click the Like button,
hit subscribe, and share
it with your friends.
If you do, we'll do
some more of them.
Deal?
And if you got some more
questions or you want
to see something else, let
us know in the comments.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show,"
and I'll see you next time.
And if you want to see-- if
you've got more questions
or want to see something else,
let us know in the comments.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show,"
and I'm going to see
you in the next take.